Silo is shaping up to be one of my
favorite shows of the year and episode 3
is another Banger that introduces new
Mysteries and clues about what the hell
is going on so we're gonna take a deep
dive into the episode skip the recap and
get only into the nitty-gritty I've left
time stamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be discussing and don't
worry I have not read the books so there
will be no spoilers but with that being
said I'll warn you near the end when we
get to my trailer spoilers section which
looks at Clues we can glean from the
trailers on where this story might be
headed now let's head on outside because
here we go the big mystery this episode
is who or what killed Mayor Ruth and
there are a lot of subtle Clues
throughout the episode that hint at what
happened from Poison water to a
mysterious nurse that I'll get into in a
bit but first why would someone want the
mayor dead it seems as though she's the
only one with the power to hire the new
sheriff otherwise the judicial would
have just steamrolled their candidate
into the position a man by the name of
Paul Billings at almost every turn Ruth
is intimidated by members of the
judicial from their enforcers watching
her from afar Sims offering her a
strawberry tart and Bernard who is
clearly on the side of Judge Meadows
although we never see her the episode
gives us two new pieces of info about
who runs the judicial a name at judge
Meadows and a sex female other than that
that's all we really know but it can be
assumed that mayor Ruth and judge
Meadows have a tumultuous pass after all
Mars notes that the mayor wanted judge
Meadows to know she wasn't coming to
visit her my guess it's judgmento's
responsible for the mayor's death now I
should mention that we never see Ruth
die it's possible that she could survive
but my guess is that she's a goner
considering the actress who plays her is
only credited as being in three episodes
but these things have been wrong in the
past so how did she die Theory one is
poisoned water check out what marn says
to Ruth early on in the episode unless
you dumped water to lighten your load I
think you got a leak it's such a strange
line of dialogue to add in if the water
had nothing to do with her death it
suggests that the mayor didn't pour
herself enough water for the long
journey to the generator which I doubt
or that it was replaced by someone else
I believe someone poured out her water
and replaced it with whatever substance
ended up making her sick to add more
fuel to this theory is that near the end
of the episode mayor Ruth asks for water
yet again so the creators have made a
concerted effort to show her drinking
from this multiple times now mayor
Ruth's water bottle is actually in
Martin's backpack I think they had their
own water bottles in each other's
backpacks to make them more accessible
or else it would suggest that a someone
was actually wanting to poison marns or
B that marns did the poisoning both of
which I doubt now Theory 2 is a lot more
far-fetched but something about it rubs
me the wrong way early on in the episode
mayor Ruth and marns visit Dr Nichols
the father of Juliet in the room is a
nurse who is dismissed so that the three
can talk in private but take a look at
this shot here the nurse is just
standing there almost eavesdropping If
This Were a simple extra there's no way
the director would allow her to stand
right in the middle of frame plus we
also get this shot and it looks as
though she's eavesdropping once again
then if you check out the end credits
she has her own credit even though she
doesn't have one word of dialogue or
anything of significance this is all
highly fishy so even if this mysterious
nurse Alice didn't have anything to do
with mayor Ruth's death she may just be
a spy for the judicial at the end of
episode 2 we learned that sheriff Becker
wanted Juliet to take over as Sheriff it
seems that historically the sheriff has
named his successor and this person
becomes more or less the next Sheriff
part of his note mentioned that if
Juliet didn't want the job that he'd at
least give her his badge and that's what
mayor Ruth gives to her albeit with a
Twist in episode 2 Sheriff Becker
promised Juliet that he would give her a
signal when he finds out more about what
happened to George she never got that
signed and watched as Becker went out
into the poison and died which is why
she called him an effing liar and
stormed out of the room but now she has
this side finding the word truth crudely
engraved on the back of his badge it's a
signal that if she takes this job she
may be able to find that truth I also
found it very odd that the two T's and H
are capitalized and the r and u are not
it's very strange and has my alarm bells
ringing now last episode I theorized
that if Juliet becomes Sheriff she'll
likely move into Becker's old apartment
at the beginning of episode 1 we see
Sheriff Becker fiddling with his
apartment's air vent and also a pot of
flowers even leaving a note that says
double the flowers in front of the
mirror I think this note is for Juliet
and that she may find something in this
flower pot that will lead her to the
event where more information that Becker
found was stored and just a reminder if
you're liking these types of videos and
want more please like And subscribe and
be sure to check out my episodes one and
two video when the power is shut down
you may have noticed this odd screen
glitch and for a brief moment the
outside world becomes that Lush
landscape Becker saw and was also seen
in the Jane Carmody file how on Earth is
it showing this beautiful scenery if the
live feed is supposed to be of the
outside world at this point we can't
take whatever is on that screen at face
value I noticed there wasn't a huge gasp
or big reaction to this glitch and none
of the silo dwellers talk about it the
camera does focus a lot of attention on
this woman who I believe is named Sandy
we saw her in the Sheriff's Office and I
think she might be some sort of
administrative assistant there if she
has a larger role expect her to team up
with the new sheriff nickels especially
if she noticed this glitch after Juliet
makes her decision to become Sheriff she
leaves Martha with whatever the heck
this device is my guess is that it's
some sort of camera or projector
evidenced by the viewfinder we see in
episode 2. because this was one of
George's relics I wonder if he's left
any recordings with this now in Martha's
possession expect this Relic to unlock
more clues the action this episode is
centered around the generator I enjoyed
the use of a cast iron spinning top to
explain how the generator is broken no
doubt a subtle nod to Inception there
are two interesting bits of information
we learn about the generator the first
is that roughly 30 years ago it
sustained damage that has caused it to
need the repair required today how did
this damage happen was it an engineer's
error or was something more nefarious at
play for now I'm keeping this info in
the back of my mind the second and far
more mysterious of the two is the origin
of the steam all they know is that it
comes from a pipe deep below now steam
doesn't just appear out of nowhere it
only appears when water transitions from
its liquid to gaseous State and this can
only happen when water reaches its
boiling point of 100 degrees Celsius so
either there's some sort of natural
geothermal heating going on that is
producing the steam or there are other
machines that the engineers aren't privy
to I also enjoyed how Bernard calls
Juliet a thief because she stole some
special heat tape and I can't help but
think this heat tape was likely used to
patch up the generator and boy oh boy do
I love seeing our Master of the friend
zone Jorah Mormont playing Juliet's
father Dr Nichols there is definitely
more going on to his relationship with
his daughter than he's letting on after
all what causes a girl to run away from
home at the age of 13 to go become an
engineer in the Deep all we really know
is that her mother and brother died and
it's implied both were suicides we'll
even see these signs for the syndrome
down in the control room which seems to
point out signs of someone who is
experiencing depression which may lead
to Suicidal Thoughts in episode 2 Juliet
tells Sheriff Becker that she knows full
well how to identify signs of the
syndrome and that George who is alleged
to have committed suicide did not
possess any of these signs part of
Juliet's character Arc this season is
learning not to run away she ran away at
age 13 and often runs away from
emotional situations with Martha Walker
who's kind of Taken on this mother
figure role for her it's interesting
then that they pair Juliet with Martha
because she's the complete opposite she
hasn't left her Workshop in 20 years
she's the furthest thing from a runner
expect more to come regarding Juliet and
her relationship with Martha and her
father we get this brief intimidating
Strawberry Tart scene with Sims but the
scene I thought was most interesting
with him was the introduction of his son
none of this propelled the plot forward
at all but it's clear they're setting up
Sims for a lot more in fact I think it's
a way to humanize him and not have us
think that he's just this soulless
enforcer here's your warning for trailer
Clues these are not book spoilers since
I haven't read the books just some Clues
we might get from The Season's trailers
that dropped a few weeks ago so turn
away if you don't want to watch check
out what appears to be a funeral here
with Bernard presiding he's wearing a
necklace that looks identical to that of
the mayor's on freedom day does Bernard
become the next mayor there are also two
corpses here with Ruth potentially dead
could this be her and Barnes notice how
Mars and mayor Ruth at least in this
shot are not in attendance however we
can catch a glimpse of now Sheriff
Nichols in the season trailer we'll also
see Bernard performing that mayoral
speech when someone is sent outside so
it also seems like another person is
going out check out this sort of glowing
fob that has the number 18 on it the
same number found that was imprinted on
the hard drive George found here's
someone falling from The Silo my guess
is that this is George and we'll get to
see the murder from his perspective
here's Sims with his son and what might
be his wife looks like Sheriff Nichols
is wasting no time investigating the
truth she has some sort of chart and it
looks as though she's trying to match
the Stars along the horizon him judging
by the tattoos on her hands it looks
like Juliet found that hard drive maybe
it's in this bag she pulls out which
looks an awful lot like the event Becker
was fidgeting with in episode 1. Juliet
reunites with her father and another
shot of her dangling over the edge of
the silo but we can't make out who's on
this other side this is quite the Brazen
attack since it's in broad daylight with
other people watching now I want to turn
it over to you and hear what your
thoughts and theories are in the
comments below be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
more questions than answers
foreign